what's going on guys welcome to another
python tutorial this one's coming from a
request i got on facebook
to show how you can change the
granularity of data being
shown on a chart so what is that in case
you don't know what granularity is it's
basically
how much data is being shown on a chart
so
in this example here with this one day
of gbp usd 4x ratio data we've got
62 000 data points well your eye
can't see the difference between 62 000
data points and like
12 000 data points the only difference
is
a minute change in like the thickness of
the line since they're
so close together it makes the line look
thicker but as far as the trajectory and
everything like that there's really no
difference there
the main difference though that is
you're being penalized for is the amount
of processing time it takes
not to load that data but actually to
draw it up on a chart so whether or not
you're using matplotlib
or you're using some other maybe a
javascript chart you're just using
python in your back end
to load the data and display it on you
know maybe some sort of web app that
you've got
the real problem and the real processing
time and the real loading time for your
user
is actually in the loading of
super high granularity data that you
don't need and the only time you need
that granularity is when you zoom into
the chart well then when you zoom
into the chart you don't even have to be
loading old
or that data that's not being shown so
there's a lot of ways that you can
use this to actually save on a ton of
performance
so that's what we'll be covering today
so this code right here is actually on
my website i'll put a link in the
description for anybody
uh that needs it i did put up the raw
code here for you guys for
modifying the granularity of data here
uh the sample code is here the web
address is just
uh capitalgbpusd.zip for zip
comes with a one day of data and
actually comes with a month of forex
tick data
so you can play with that if you want
but for the video we'll just be using
the one day
and then here is the actual sample code
and then i've also
just included some images here this
would be 62 000 plots so the full 62 000
then with the function that we'll be
writing in this tutorial this is
one-fifth of that so 12 000 plots
basically
you really can't tell the difference
between these two charts again other
than the thickness of the line see like
right here it just looks a little
thicker
um simply because there's more points
and so it just you know gives the
impression that that line is thicker but
it's not um and then this was one
fifteenth granularity
again you didn't really lose too much
you did lose the highs and the lows
right the this line peaks a little bit
lower
than the original line which is slightly
above this dotted line
then we come down here and it's almost
kissing that dotted line
but for the main focus of you know the
point of granularity is to save on
loading time and show the data that
matters
um and so it's it's definitely a huge a
huge help and you don't have to go down
to 1 15
right we've already shown you know a
fifth of the granularity saves a ton
on processing and you don't really lose
too much
so that's what we're going to be doing
in this video we'll actually write a
function
where you can choose how much you know
granularity you actually want
so go to the link in description get the
sample data and get that starting code
that will look
just like this basically so now what we
actually want to do is go ahead and
write
a function to do this now really as with
anything i mean there's
just you know pretty much an infinite
number of ways that we could do this
but what we're going to do is just
depending on the granularity
we're basically going to average that
data so that's usually how
most charting applications are going to
do it if they offer granularity
changes as they just take a group of
data and they average it so
that's what we're going to be doing uh
to change this since this was
you know some old code uh that i just
wanted to take it's some code that
displays some high granularity data so
that's why i'm using it
so what we want to do is we're going to
go ahead and take this part the the part
where we define
all the data and we're just going to
move it out of here
so we can call it in a function so just
hit you know control x to cut it
and paste it up there and that's all we
really need to do there
now let's define a function uh we're
going to call this function
uh define change granularity so
we're just going to call it change
granularity then we're going to pass
three variables through it one is going
to be the x variable one will be the y
variable and the third one is going to
be div by and that's going to be like
how much do you want to divide this data
by
so 5 15 4500 whatever
so now we've done that we're gonna
define two variables we're gonna have
grand
x and that's just gonna equal whatever
was passed through this x
then we're gonna have grand y and that's
gonna equal whatever's passed through
the
y now we're also gonna have two empty
arrays it'll be changed
grand x empty array changed
grand y empty array and if you can't
guess
that's where we're going to populate
with the new data
so next what we're going to do is we're
going to say um
you know granularity of x basically like
where are we currently
is going to be the length of whatever
was passed through x you could also use
the length of whatever was passed
through y
we basically just want to know where are
we starting and now what we're going to
do is kind of actually work backwards
because depending on the size of the
data like let's say
you're working with data that is 1099
data points long
and you decide you want to do a 100
granularity on that or divide it by a
hundred
if you went from zero starting at the
zeroth point and started averaging stuff
uh you might and you would in theory
miss out on the last 100 points so we
actually want to start at the
latest point and work our way back when
it comes to averaging
so any missing data or any data that
doesn't have enough data to be averaged
will be
the end data not the most recent data
so what we're going to go ahead and do
now is say wow gx
oops sorry it's lowercase g capital x
is greater than whatever we're dividing
by
um so let's say we're doing a 5. so
while gx because we're starting at the
gx being equal to the length of the data
that we're passing through
and so as long as it's greater than
whatever we're planning to divide by
then we're going to do this and that way
as long as at the end of this we're
going to you know do a little minus
equals
of div by so we move by chunks of data
so uh we're gonna say x list
uh and that's gonna equal whatever grand
x is
and then we're gonna do g x minus
uh div by and so that's our starting
point and whatever this
like you know this list of x variables
is and then we're going to go all the
way to wherever we
are right now with gx because this is
what we'll be modifying
so it'll just be gx minus div by to gx
so let's say
uh we're using a you know 15 div by
uh and we're at the 1000th variable
right now
for gx so it would be gx minus div by so
gx minus 15 so
1 000 minus 15 so for all you math
majors out there that would be 985
2 gx which would be a thousand so 985 to
1000
is what list we'd be considering now
what do we want to do with that list
well with both x
and y we want to just average it so date
in this scenario is being passed through
a numpy
load text operation and we're converting
it using m dates
so we're converting that date and it
converts it so you can either use a unix
timestamp to pass through
x so x is your date variable usually
right if you're using dates obviously
if you're not using dates and this is a
number then you don't even need to worry
about what i might be happening about
but if you are using dates before you
would pass it through this operation
you'd either have to convert that date
stamp to a unix timestamp
or convert it to this little m date
stamp which is
not unix i don't know what it is but
it's something
so anyway keep that in mind
it must be a number right because you're
going to average it so
yeah anyway so grand x that's what we're
going to do with grand
x now what we want to do you guys
average it so we're going to say x
a v g and we're going to we're going to
do an averaging
operation uh if you don't know what
lambda is i do have a tutorial on lambda
it's
like a way to write a quick one line
throwaway function
um and yeah so you can watch that
tutorial on lambda it's called
wtf is lambda or something like that so
now
reduce and we're going to use lambda
and again this is we're just doing this
so we can average everything and our
variables our parameters for this lambda
will be x and y
then we're just going to say x plus y
and then we're going to do this
on the x list so that adds up everything
in the list
and then what do we want to do well we
want to divide it by
the length of x list now
the problem here even though luckily
we're using float data
you you could in theory have some data
that
is all whole numbers so when you do this
equation
it would actually return to you a forced
whole number not a uh
you know something with decimal points
so just to save ourselves from ever
having to worry about that we're going
to convert this to div
by or well i can't say div by that i
guess i
might confuse some people what we're
dividing by
turn that to a float so it forces this
to return a float
just so we're safe now the next thing
we're going to do
i'll make some space is now we're going
to do our
y list so we're going to go ahead and
just do the y thing here so i realize g
x we're mostly just using the length of
x just so we know how long the data is
but we might as well do both conversions
within the same while loop and save our
processing so y list will equal
basically
this only we're going to use um
well grand y instead the rest of the
variables we can continue using
so i'm just going to copy this paste
this and change that x
to a y we can still use g x because
again it's just referencing the length
of data
so we'll leave that there now we're
going to say
y avg equals reduce and actually yeah
let's go ahead and copy and paste this
averaging function as well might as well
do that
paste and now we need to change this to
y list
and this to y list and the rest of it
will stay the same so we're just going
to average both of these lists now and
that's what's
where we're at now so now that we've
averaged these we need to append them
um to our array here and so what this is
actually going to wind up doing
if you have it depends on your charting
application but if you have kind of a
crude charting application in what we're
about to do is going to
in reverse order populate this array
that might be problematic for some of
you guys so if it is
i highly suggest you watch my tutorial
on how to reverse
the order of a list um that'll probably
that'll be like the video right before
this one
but you can also search it or if i re if
i remember to do it i'll put the link in
the description since
that will cause some trouble for some of
you guys depending on your charting
application
um so yeah so changed grand
x dot append and we want to append the x
uh average and then we're gonna do
changed grand
y dot append y avg
finally the last operation we must do is
going to be g x
minus equals whatever we're dividing by
that way it continues uh running through
this and then finally there's no more
space it stops this while loop stops
populating these arrays and we're ready
to
bebop on our way the last thing we want
to do then now that we're out of that
while loop is we want to return
whatever the x variable was now and
that's the changed granularity of it and
then we also want to return the change
grand
y so now when we're all done
um we're ready to chart i'm going to
leave
this regular graph raw fx here and i'm
just literally going to just highlight
this and paste the second one down here
i'm going to hit
graw or graph raw fx2
and let's go ahead and call the first
one real quick just so we can see that
it is
uh working so graph raw fx so we'll save
that
run that and it'll take a second because
it's got to load up all that data
and then draw all that data but here it
is now so you can see that this is our
regular chart now let's actually do a
graph
gosh i can't say graph raw graph
raw fx2 now we haven't made any changes
so we need to make our changes
and i'm going to go ahead and comment
out this other calling of that one
and now what we want to do is we're
going to come up here
and we're going to call that previous uh
we're going to call this changed
granularity function
so let me just copy and paste uh this
because we are
just for remembering purposes now
paste it out so um so this the data that
we have is bid
and ask right so we've got basically two
bits of data that we want to convert
so the first one we'll just say bid
grand
x and then we'll say bid
ran y equals and then it's going to be
change brand new larity
and our x variable uh is date and our y
variable will be bid for now
and then let's just for the first round
we'll cut it in into
into five right so we'll divide it by
five then we're going to do the exact
same thing again
uh with ask grand x ask
grand y equals change granularity
date ask five now we want to fix this
data
right so we're going to just literally
copy and paste
into here uh y variable then
ask gran x over date ask
grand y over ask
and we're set um oh shoot we
we modified the original uh why didn't
anybody tell me i was doing that
uh so depending on which function you
edited
uh let me just change this i'm gonna
leave this as grout graph raw fx2
or graph raw effects down here
this is graph raw fx2
so if you were doing as i said not as i
did um
you were editing graph raw man i can't
say that
graph raw fx2 but if you were following
along just take note that you'll have to
like you want to change the name of this
function so on whatever function you
were just editing
change that to 2 and make sure the
original function just leave that as it
is
so now we're going to actually plot
graph
raw fx2 now just for kicks let's go
ahead and just
print land date and then we'll print
len of bid grand
x so now let's save that run that
wait for that chart to pop up for us
dude yeah okay so here's our chart
obviously it looks
very similar and now you can see the
original data was 62 012
data points long for each variable and
now each variable is only
twelve thousand four hundred data points
long so i mean we're talking
um well a fifth of the data
yet i mean no real visible change now
what if we change this
to like uh 105
right let's really affect this and run
it again
now you can obviously see i mean there's
been a huge change right well obviously
because we went from 62
000 points to now only 590 points but i
mean as far as trajectory
is concerned in the actual you know
pattern of the line
we're seeing very little difference
right your only change is from the
absolute high to the absolute low but if
you look at the actual data points here
this is 1559
this is 1560 right or 1.560
1.559 and this data
only goes to four it goes to four
decimal points right and so you
lose you know a little bit of data the
original maybe
had this peak here all the way up to
about here and it made it a little
shorter basically
um but as far as you know the actual
pattern of the line i mean we've got
no major change you know and that was a
huge change like nobody's going to be
doing that
but like you know 5 or 15 is going to
make a massive difference
on um the loading time of your charts
and also the drawing time like 62 000 i
mean
it sounds like a lot of data 62 000 data
points really isn't
that much data for matplotlib to plot up
honestly
um when you start getting into like the
millions i guess it sort of depends on
what kind of machine you're running on
but when you start getting data into
like the
millions or the 10 millions then the
division of granularity helps you
so much and as you saw from like
you know from on a chart of that size
62 000 data points you can see just fine
12 000 data points
you can see just fine right so if you're
plotting like let's say you had a
million
data points on your chart and you know
that uh 12 000 data points
looks just the same as you know a
million data points or however many data
points you've got on there
you can in theory divide your data by 83
or something like that right that's
as close as it gets a million divided by
12 000.
so uh obviously like the higher your
data is right that you're trying to
stuff into a little chart that's like
six inches by four inches uh you know
you can really make some massive changes
to it
so anyways hopefully that answers some
of y'all's questions i had gotten a few
questions on that and then finally
decided to go ahead and make a make a
tutorial on
on how you can divide up your data like
that without killing yourself
uh so hopefully you guys have learned
something useful as always thanks for
watching thanks for the support the
subscriptions and until next time